I've experienced like certain traumas
like as I've gotten older right and I've
noticed that my body like because your
muscles store this trauma and I've
noticed that my body can go into
the trauma right if I'm if I'm triggered
by something whatever it may be and so
for me I'm like oh [__] like I need to
work on this to figure out how to get
through this and pass this trauma so I
literally don't physically react like
I'll I won't be able to like eat and
I'll be like hunched over and I'll be
like in pain like nauseous I'm like why
can't I just talk myself out of this and
I really do believe that it is because
your muscles store this memory
and so your memory is like the trauma
thing oh it's connected to everything
right right yeah and so and it might not
have anything to do with what the trauma
was about but it's it's
probably has something to do with what
the trauma is about but and it just
brings that out and that's the hardest
thing and so I've heard a lot about
is it EMDR yeah I did it you did it I
was gonna say it how was it
mind-boggling like in a good way I went
in and I've always heard the story like
once right
I mean 280 episodes
thank you Ryan
[Laughter]
um so I I went to this place because I
just needed to clear my head my friend
Zach Levi went there he was there and he
was like he's like I think you should go
there and I go all right fine expensive
but I was like you know thank God I
could afford it I'm gonna go
and there were
one of the uh classes one of the uh
therapists was an EMDR specialist and I
went in there and uh we did like
sessions and they go look I don't even
know if I'm right candidate for this I'm
already doubting myself trying I gotta
be great in this EMDR session she goes
we're not going to do that today like
okay and we talked and then the next
session we're going going she goes oh
and we're not going to do it today and I
go okay and at the end of that session
she asked me something and I mentioned
something about my childhood jokingly
I go oh yeah and then and then this
happened it was just like you're stupid
and you know and Farley and then I do
that every once in a while and then and
then the therapist goes she she goes
I think we're ready to do this I go uh
why don't we get like 10 minutes left
and then she goes no do you want to do
this now I I think we should do like oh
okay don't do anything
I want you to close your eyes
I want you to close your eyes and I want
you to think of that moment and when you
think around your surround about your
surroundings what you were doing the
feeling you had and I wanted and I
started to think about that and really
go there and she goes then I want you to
open your eyes and follow my finger and
I kept doing it doing it I'm like this
is bananas but I stay with it I said I'm
here for a reason and uh and she goes
okay close your eyes
what do you see and I said blah blah
blah blah blah the second time I opened
my eyes
hysterical crying crying it came out of
nowhere where I wasn't even trying tears
were just flowing I'm like whoa I can't
do this with acting you know and uh it
went on and on and on for about 20
minutes
and then I opened my eyes and she said
and it was kind of uh there was a
through line there was sort of the whole
thing you know it started here emotional
emotional motion build build and then by
the end I just
therapist said well what are you
thinking and I go
and all that came to me was
I forgive them oh wow
I forgive them and I was crying and I
was like
they didn't they did the best that they
could do and it was not good and I
didn't deserve it and whatever
and it was so cathartic
and she says what it does is it's like a
big tree in the forest that one big tree
you just knocked down so now with the
MDR when you think about that because I
would think about that story a lot and
if I didn't bother I mean obviously
subconsciously bothered yeah it was just
in there and
I don't think about it anymore and if I
do if I try to think of it it doesn't
affect me wow and that big tree also
knocks down some little trees too so it
helps with other things but the more you
do it
the better so right